welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and it's time to put a smile on that
face with our breakdown of the 100 best
easter eggs in batman begins
our journey begins with the batman logo
appearing on screen
after being formed by a cauldron of bats
yes that's the name used to describe a
group of them
anyway why this is important is because
the logo kick-starts every single movie
in the trilogy
and with it comes a lot of symbolism and
double meaning batman begins is created
by
bats as these become integral to the
entry the theme of the film is fear
and overcoming it and bruce at one point
throws himself into the mists of them
when exploring the cave in order to
overcome his fear
and thus become the hero that the city
needs the dark knight starts off with
the symbol flying through a blue fire
and to me this represents how the joker
is someone that wants to watch the world
burn
but that batman will always be there to
stop him the dark knight rises has the
symbol created through ice cracking
and a large part of that film takes
place in the winter
and involves bane breaking batman cut to
a young bruce taking an arrowhead
and he then falls down a well this shot
would later be echoed in the dark knight
rises when bruce is climbing out of the
pit
and symbolically this moment kickstarts
a motif that would come full circle in
that film
here bruce has to be helped out of it by
his father but come the third film he's
able to do it himself
showing that he has been able to rise
pun intended now this
well is the entrance to the cave and as
we see it's swarming with bats
which create nightmares for bruce and
tie back to his fear
the character even wakes up in a prison
haunted by these dreams
and we discover that his fear of bats in
some ways led to his parents death
thus him confronting bats is also
confronting the trauma that has driven
him
and it's a nice way of layering
everything into one cohesive narrative
when bruce is listening to his father's
heartbeat at one point
we can also see little bat symbols on
his sweater
and these would appear as the signal in
the dark knight rises
lacing the movie with an even deeper
subtext
not too long after bruce meets ducard
and is then released from prison
ducat is actually a character in the
comics that trained bruce to be a
detective
and at the time it was a big twist to
learn that he'd actually been razz algul
the whole time
i know it's typically pronounced race
but as they call him raz
to keep it consistent i'm just going to
call him that throughout the breakdown
he makes a journey across the rocky
cavernous icelands
and this location was also echoed in the
first justice league trailer
so we may see something similar in the
snyder cut when it releases next year
bruce ends up getting trained by the
league of shadows who in the comics are
called the league of assassins
batman of course has a no killing rule
so this was likely changed because the
character
wouldn't shack up with a bunch of
murderous ninjas
now bruce is told that theatricality and
deception are powerful agents of the
league of shadows
this foreshadows their plan as they of
course want to drug the city and
hallucinating their deepest fears
so that they can tear themselves apart
the things that they see
will not be there in real life and
therefore it will be a deception that
preys upon that theatrics that their
mind can create
in order to take them down align there
to play on this
of course returns in the dark knight
rises when bane says the atrocity and
deception
are powerful agents to the uninitiated
this confirms that he was amongst their
ranks
and likely trained by ryze himself raz
also says he wants to restore balance to
the world
which talia also hints towards at the
party in the dark knight rises
by saying something similar from here
bruce slips into a nightmare once more
in which we learn about what drives him
bruce visits the opera with his
parents and in many ways the performers
that he sees inspire his costume
there's a character wearing bad ears
that can be seen and the main costumes
that scare bruce
involve performers in black dangling
from ropes
batman of course uses ropes to get
around the city and black cloth to glide
now the opera itself is called
mephistophele
which i've definitely pronounced strong
because i sit around watching batman
movies all day instead of going to the
opera
but this story actually has several tie
backs to the film itself
and the plot can be seen echoing bruce's
journey the piece is about the devil
trying to corrupt the character faust
into helping him complete his goal now
if you take this and apply it to the
characters in the movie
the devil represents razal ghoul and
bruce could be seen as a stand-in for
faust
the goal is to destroy gotham but much
like the story
things don't go the devil's way
ultimately
faust turns to god and takes a different
path much like how bruce turns to batman
and it's nice that the symbolism is
laced highly in the opera
there's also a similar idea of immortal
turning to god at the end of the movie
when raz invades bruce's home bruce says
there are good people
in gotham when pleading with the villain
not to destroy the city
and in the bible abraham used the same
argument when pleading with god
not to destroy sodom and gomorrah sodom
and gomorrah was rotten to the core
and much like raz god wanted to destroy
the city
because it was too far gone i absolutely
love these metaphors and bruce's parents
are killed in front of him by jo
chill who also carried out this crime in
the comics
there's also the tearing of the pills
which are infamous throughout batman's
history
and bruce drops to his knees which echo
the panels from batman year one
his father tells him not to be afraid
and we can also hear a single choir boy
singing a note very hauntingly
this single voice of a young boy of
course represents bruce
who is now completely alone in the world
well he has alfred i suppose but you
know what i mean
now next we meet jim gordon for the
first time and he puts his coat around
the boy which is brought up again at the
end of the dark knight rises
so that batman can reveal his true
identity to the character
you also meet commissioner loeb who
actually seems like a nice guy
unlike his comic book counterpart in
batman year one who's pretty much
helping to cause corruption in the city
cut back to bruce sparring with ryze
over an iced over lake
and though b-boy seems to win razz takes
him out by cracking the ice which makes
him fall through it
this is echoed in the dark knight rises
when the prisoners are forced to wander
out onto ice
and they fall through which eventually
leads to their deaths
razz says you never learn to mind your
surroundings which pops up again
later in the movie with bruce using his
environment to beat the character
similar to what the villain does here
raz helps bruce to warm up
and he tells them of his family and how
they were taken from him
this of course returns in the dark
knight rises when we see the backstory
of talia
and how she and her mother were taken
from him by a vicious warlord
now we later see another subtle detail
that links the two
and this comes during the scene in which
the fake raz al ghoul picks up a
branding iron
on the end of it we can make out what
seems to be a shark tooth like mark
and in the dark knight rises bruce
notices a scar on talia's back
after the two get it on that looks quite
similar jump to joe chill getting
murdered by one of falcone's henchmen
and we see as he's shot outside the
courtroom with god surrounding him
this is actually referencing the
infamous image in which lee harvey
oswald was assassinated by jack ruby
i think thomas wayne might have actually
been made to look slightly like jfk
in order to bring up the similarities
with chill killing a high-ranking member
of society
before being murdered himself probably
reaching with that though but
you know we do like a good reach now
rachel takes bruce downtown and says
things are worse than ever which is a
line that reappears in the dark knight
at the press conference when harvey
claims to be batman
bruce ends up leaving and he throws the
gun away that he was going to use on
chill
showing that he won't be part of this
cycle of violence and
eye for an eye mentality he swaps his
coat with a homeless man
and hey you know what that is a nice
coat this character appears later in the
movie
when he just so happens to be standing
in pretty much the exact same place
that he has for all these years now but
why this is important
is because metaphorically bruce getting
rid of his coat is also symbolic of him
getting rid of his bruce wayne identity
so that he can go off and carve out a
new one bruce actually
keeps this homeless guy's coat for a
while and we can see her being worn with
the sleeves torn off when he steals in
order to feed himself
bruce ends up destroying the league of
shadow base and because raz is
unconscious during this
he doesn't know what happened to him so
believes that bruce left him for dead
even though that guy promised him he'd
tell him that he saved his life
i don't know if i'm reading into that
but raz does later say that he left him
for dead
so i'm sorry guy you had one job and you
messed it up
now bruce comes back to gotham and we
also meet jonathan crane
who we discover is the scarecrow similar
to bruce he uses a mask to drive fear
into people
but unlike everyone's favorite wayne he
does it for personal gain
rather than for others this is victor
zazz's court hearing
and you may know this character as the
infamous serial killer in the batman
universe
zaz also appeared in birds of prey but
both of these versions are sort of toned
down
from what's in the comics now in the
source material every time zaz kills
someone he cuts his skin to leave a
score
and we can actually see them along his
neck just above his shirt
jogger too used scars as a symbol of
trauma in the dark knight
so it may even be possible that zaz
inspired the interpretation that nolan
took
towards the clown cut to wayne tower and
we get to meet several of the board
members who actually returned throughout
the trilogy
you also meet lucius fox and are
introduced to the armory that bane would
later robin rises
the camouflage tumbler is also shown
here which appears in that film
and due to the colours used on it it's
likely that it was part of the iraq war
we discovered that batman's body armor
was deemed too expensive for soldiers
and thus there is very much this idea of
it all being linked to that real-world
conflict
the taliban were also trained by the cia
in the 80s
and they took this knowledge and used it
against the west
much like how bane took the weapons that
batman used to protect the city
and turned them against it the league of
shadows are of course situated in the
east
and whilst this may be a reach there are
many callbacks
and i did tell you it would be a reach
dinner now why this is interesting
is because there exists a theory that
the joker was actually an iraq war vet
who suffered ptsd and using his military
training
he decided to destabilize gotham the
dark knight is often seen as a metaphor
for the time period
due to the surveillance protocols that
batman carries out to spy on the gotham
citizens
bush and the cia were accused of doing
this as well so potentially we have
all three films tying back to the war in
some interesting ways not long after
we're taken to the bat cave and see
bruce putting the foundations in
this would of course become advanced in
the third film of the trilogy
but there are some notable aspects of
dialogue here alfred says the caverns
were used by his ancestors to help
slaves move as part of the underground
railroad
and this very much echoes how bruce's
father tried to build an actual railroad
to unite the city
bruce also spray paints the suit with
black latex paint
and this is actually capable of hiding
the heat signature from things
so that it would keep him invisible to
infrared shortly after
we meet back up with gordon who as we
see has been partnered up with detective
flass
in the book year one this was also the
case and similar to what we see here the
character was very crooked and corrupt
bruce goes to gordon and holds a stapler
to his head in order to make him think
he has a gun
and he ends up having to dive off the
rooftop of the gcpd
which goes badly so he has to don a cape
i always thought this costume here was
kind of similar to what he had in the
animated movie mask of the phantasm
when going out on his first night but
again i don't know if i'm reaching yet
tell me if i am now the masking wears
also appears in the dark knight rises
when bruce visits gordon in the hospital
and it's a nice little call back to this
moment that brings everything full
circle bruce confronts falcone down at
the dock area again
but this time he's completely
transformed i love how falcone was both
his last criminal interaction in the
city
and also his first and yet this scene is
just absolutely amazing
nolan shoots it from the perspective of
the criminals and we really see that
batman becomes a monster in the mind of
his enemies
now i'm batman i'm batman has been said
so many times by so many people
a lot better than i have over the years
that it's almost a running gag at this
point
and it's something that matt reeves
actually played with in the trailer for
his upcoming robert pattinson movie
in that he has the characters say that
he's vengeance instead of what we all
suspected
but hey i still like saying i'm batman
a batman puts falconi on his spotlight
and this creates the bat symbol for the
first time
but it also has another meaning falcone
is publicly crucified for all in the
city to see
whilst we get the idea that batman will
be watching over them
the night goes well but alfred doesn't
seem too impressed
and the next day he tells bruce that he
has to play up being a playboy
in order to avoid suspicion his list of
things to do include driving sports cars
something that we see him doing that
night dating movie stars
which he also does later that night and
lastly buying things that aren't for
sale
which the character does when purchasing
the hotel so that his chums can play in
the fountain
sports car bruce drives is also the
lamborghini
marchalago which is spanish for bat
batman then goes to flas
and pulls him up using his grappling gun
so that the character is face to face
with him
this shot would later be echoed at the
end of the dark knight with the joker
and it shows that flash and batman have
opposing ideologies
bats are also infamous for hanging
upside down
so i like how bruce has used this to
strike fear into his enemies
batman also comes face to face with
joffrey and i don't care about this no
killing rule yet
just get him while you still can't get
him while he's young if he could
would you go back in time and kill
joffrey as a kid
because i would anyway off topic there's
also this idea of the drugs being moved
through rabbits and bears rabbits are
actually
important as they're symbolic of alice
in wonderland which involves
hallucinations and weird things being
seen
though the mad hatter isn't in this
trilogy similar to the scarecrow he uses
techniques to make people see things
that aren't there
and thus i think this rabbit inclusion
and the similarities of the character
are done on purpose as a little nod to
him now that might be a reach
but i tell you what isn't a reach you
reaching for that subscribe button
and also clicking the thumbs up we do
videos like this each and every day
so if you're enjoying this and i thought
i'd drop a reminder here
you know doing the casual begging people
to subscribe stuff
never goes down well but hopefully it
does here and you know i love you
anyway batman is sprayed with crane's
fear toxin and he begins to imagine bats
crawling out of the character's mouth
showing that bruce is still
subconsciously scared of them
batman gets set on fire and has to be
rescued by alfred
which mirrors how the mansion is set on
fire after he's saved by the butler
now rachel meets with crane and he
discusses how scarecrows are pillars of
fear
this is true and though not typically
used to scare away bats
in general scarecrows are used to drive
fear into birds
so that they don't land in fields crane
drugs rachel
and actually gets a taste of his own
medicine when batman turns the toxin on
him
we see how batman is viewed in the eyes
of his enemies and it's one of my
favorite scenes in the entire movie
batman has come full circle and now
represents the fear-inducing monster
that he believed the bats to be
the gcpd swarmed the building and batman
calls him back up
namely bats which the character also did
to escape the police in the graphic
novel year one
batman races through the streets and
rooftops on the tumbler
and i had this scene room for me so i'm
gonna do the same for you
now one of the cops on the carpark roof
who tells bruce to stop
actually reappears as the policeman
questioning what the vehicle looks like
which he shouldn't have as he was on the
rooftop and you already knew
and you know what i'm i'm really glad
i've just spoiled that for you because
because you suck unless you hit the
subscribe button which in which case i
love you now bruce returns to his
birthday party
and we see his razz uses another stan in
to trick him
this character wears a green coat which
is similar to what the real one does in
the comics
raz hints to raz algul being immortal
and though in the film
this is merely theatricality and
deception in the comics it goes far
beyond that
the source material has raz using
lazarus pits which are basically the
fountain of youth to keep him young
so it's nice that they grounded it here
with the idea that he's only immortal
due to his tricks bruce actually ruins
his reputation in order to save the
people at the party
and he ends up taking the blame in order
to cover up the truth of what's
happening
the character would do something similar
at the end of the dark night to stop the
truth about harvey dent from destroying
the city
and i love how he's always willing to
throw himself under the bus
he also says that it's not a joke and
calls them two-faced friends
and both the joker and two-face appear
as villains in the dark knight
so this is a good bit of foreshadowing
and also a good bit of reaching yeah you
know i love it
what's interesting is that raz in some
ways caused the waynes to be killed
but the movie doesn't force it down our
throats and the connection is
only there if you want it to be razz
spreads fear throughout the city
and i think that everyone's lucky no one
turned on a kettle for months
as had they done it they would have
breathed in the gas
which yeah this this is just a bit of a
plot hole isn't it
now the narrows are completely bombarded
and scarecrow arrives on a horse
this is actually a call back to when the
character did something similar
in the graphic novel the long halloween
he utters the line there's nothing to
fear but fear
itself which is a call back to when fdr
said it in 1933.
batman fights raz on the train which is
heading towards the water main
and this battle is symbolic as he's
facing off against his somewhat
surrogate father
on the thing his real father built raz
also says don't be afraid bruce
which is the last thing that thomas said
to the character before passing away
bruce destroys carriages on the train in
a weird fashion
but this is actually done on purpose so
that his cake can catch the wind
and allow him to glide out there now in
crashing the train
bruce destroys his surrogate dad along
with his real dad's legacy
all in one fell swoop he has finally
become his own man without the need for
their guidance
and he triumphantly flies over the city
he does this in front of wayne tower
showing how both wayne and batman are
one in the same and it's
a nice little marriage of the two
personas bruce forcing an algool in a
vehicle to go
tumbling over the edge of something
before they die is also the same thing
that happens to talia in the dark knight
rises
and even the music is the same about
their deaths as they go over the edge
the movie has a touching scene between
rachel and bruce
in which he says that the mask he wears
now is his true face
and this is actually something that a
lot of people have tackled with over the
years
i've always viewed bruce as the mask and
she promises to love him again when he
finally comes back
which is something that the dark knight
tackles cut of the bat symbol being made
and bruce meets gordon on the roof
which is where we get a tease of the
joker the calling card is actually
written up by officer j
kerr which is of course an alias of the
character
gordon goes to thank batman but the dark
knight says he'll never have to
but i tell you who does need to thank
you me for doing this video
so if you enjoyed it then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of avengers end game
which will be linked at the end
we go over the 200 best easter eggs in
the movie
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
can also come chat is on a discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you